The Voice winner Jordan Smith rang in
the new year with a new fiance now he's
telling ET that he picked out that
stunning sparkler all on his own so I
kinda did it all myself and figured
everything out didn't ask her anything I
said it all my own but thank God it's
hard to have it turned out okay she
liked this how surprised were you I was
very surprised I wasn't expecting it at
all and how's the wedding planning going
it's it's coming along we actually just
celebrated our like one-month
anniversary of being engaged like a
couple days ago so it's going well it's
happening quickly and we're doing a lot
of it apart right now just because I've
been working in a studio like crazy and
been in LA but it's going well we're
excited are you thinking it'll be a
quick engagement or are you taking your
time with it just how much time we'll be
able to take I think I think those
things will probably pretty quickly all
right now tell us about the album how's
it going in the studio it's it's
actually going so great everything is
pretty much wrapped up we're almost
finished and so I think we can expect it
to come out really really soon which is
a good thing I mean I'm dying chomping
us a bit ready to get some new music out
for everybody it's gonna be happening
pretty soon this spring now has Adam
been helping you at all through this
process after the boys Adam and I have
been able to stay in touch and he just
like thanks to check in on me sometimes
to make sure I'm doing okay
he hasn't been a part of the album per
se yet but yeah he's definitely been
checking in how's it been for you
watching him achieve his dreams and
recording his debut album it's been
really exciting and it's is something
that Jordans talked about for as long as
we've been together so it's really
awesome to get to see him
Billy Stearn